[Música]
a inicios de 1982 una de las epidemias
más grandes del cólera se esparcía a
través de la ciudad de parís en medio de
todo este caos y león bélico un
prominente científico de la época tomó
una decisión que para muchos nosotros
nos parecería sorprendente
él decidió que la manera más rigurosa de
poder es esta enfermedad involucraba a
tomar a la misma bacteria del cólera
increíblemente y entre todo pronóstico
el enfermo
intrigado por los resultados médicos
decido reclutar a dos de esos colegas
para poder entender mejor lo que estaba
sucediendo mientras que el primero no
desarrolla ninguna enfermedad el segundo
cayó gravemente enfermo y al por muy
poco literalmente por muy poco no murió
qué era lo que estaba sucediendo que
hacía que algunas personas ante la
presencia del cólera cayeran enfermas e
incluso llegaran a la muerte mientras
que otras parecidas a ser inmunes a este
después de muchos experimentos y pruebas
en el laboratorio técnico descubrió que
la respuesta se encontraba dentro de
cada uno de nosotros él descubrió que
algunas de las bacterias que habitan en
nuestro sistema digestivo podrían ser la
diferencia entre la vida y la muerte
estas bacterias esencialmente podrían
servir como una primera línea de defensa
lo que permitía ante la presencia del
cólera poder destruirlas antes de que
ésta nos causen una infección
este fue el primer ejemplo que demostró
que algunas de las bacterias que viven
dentro de nosotros podrían tener efectos
muy positivos para nuestra salud
ahora sabemos que las bacterias que
viven dentro de nosotros forman parte de
una comida mucho más grande y amplia de
microorganismos los cuales en conjunto
denominamos microbioma él como el
microbioma es extremadamente abundante
tanto así que dentro de cada uno de
nosotros aproximadamente 10 billones de
estas bacterias que nos habitan
para darle una idea de que tan
abundantes son las bacterias benéficas
que viven dentro de nosotros si
pudiéramos contar todas las células de
nuestro cuerpo literalmente de pies a
cabeza
nosotros nos daríamos cuenta que éstas
superan a nuestras células humanas en
una proporción de 10 a 1
más aún estas células son altamente
diversas gracias a nuevos métodos
bioquímicos ahora podemos leer el adn
que se encuentra dentro de cada una de
estas
y esto nos permitirá descubrir en
aproximadamente 10.000 especies
diferentes viven dentro dentro de cada
uno de nosotros estas bacterias pueden
desarrollar habilidades únicas
habilidades que incluso nuestras células
humanas no pueden desarrollar
lo que les permiten producir una serie
de compuestos benéficos los cuales
pueden incluso tener efectos muy
positivos para nuestra salud una de esos
compuestos es la serotonina la
serotonina es esencialmente un aero
transmisor que permite la comunicación
entre neuronas increíblemente a pensar
crecer también es usada principalmente
en nuestro cerebro esta es producida en
su mayoría dentro de nuestros intestinos
y esto es sorprendente porque nadie se
esperaría que pudiera existir un vínculo
tan cercano entre estas células
benéficas de nuestro microbioma y
nuestra felicidad
ahora sabemos que nutrieron puede
cumplir roles mucho más diversos e
incluso puede estar involucrada en
enfermedades estas dos personas
tienen microbiomas sumamente diversos y
esto se ve porque la persona de la
derecha en promedio es una persona
saludable mientras que la persona de la
izquierda es una persona que presenta
obesidad sus pruebas son tan diversos y
tan diferentes que solo basándonos en su
composición podríamos predecir hasta un
90 por ciento de confianza si una
persona tiene obesidad o no es más ahora
sabemos que algunos componentes del
microbioma puede incluso transmitir
ciertas
ciertas características de la enfermedad
estos dos ratones aunque ustedes lo
crean son ratones gemelos 5 semanas dice
que se tomará esta foto estas razones
tenían el mismo peso
la única diferencia es que en uno de
estos se cambio en la dieta y lo que se
hizo es introducir bacterias
provenientes de un donante obeso de un
donante humano uefa y como pueden ver
genera un cambio drástico en su peso
ahora sabemos que estas bacterias pueden
tener muchos más roles en el año pasado
a medida que esta cando y el doctorado a
la universidad de berkeley nosotros
empezamos a desarrollar una startup ya
tecnológica enfocada en en el área del
microbioma lo que nosotros realizamos es
esencialmente generar soluciones para
que cuando bacterias dañinas nos tratan
de infectar no lo puedan hacer
normalmente cuando uno tiene un problema
uno va al doctor y este después de hacer
una serie de chequeos y pruebas
normalmente determinará recomendando un
antibiótico lo que nosotros estamos
realizando es una forma alternativa a
los antibióticos y esto es porque los
antibióticos a pesar de que si
efectivamente pueden matar a las
bacterias dañinas también a la misma vez
termina destruyendo todas las bacterias
benéficas que son parte de nuestro
microbioma
nosotros lo que estamos usando son
bacterias fagos los bacteriófagos son
esencialmente unos virus que son parte
de nuestro microbioma y ante ciertas
condiciones pueden ser usados para
destruir a bacterias
sin embargo estos virus contrario a la
mayoría de virus que nosotros conocemos
no son malos estos virus pueden ser muy
buenos
nosotros lo que estamos haciendo el
laboratorio es modificarlos en su
estructura genética de tal manera que
podamos hacerlos mucho más eficientes
y específicos
de tal manera que en vez de ser usaron
antibióticos que especialmente son un
arma destrucción masiva nosotros
podíamos podamos usar bacteria falso
esta es una bacteria que ha sido
invadida por bacteria favor cinco
minutos después de esta toma esta
bacteria estará totalmente destruida
en el último año hemos realizado mucho
progreso hemos podido desarrollar una
librería de bacteriófagos ante diversas
bacterias hemos podido modificarlos para
poder aumentar sus capacidades y
esperamos movernos hacia la clínica en
los próximos años sin embargo ustedes ya
tienen la capacidad de tomar algunas
acciones benéficas que pueden ser buenas
para su salud por ejemplo ustedes pueden
tener tener una dieta rica en fibra
vegetal ya que a pesar que la fibra
vegetal no es digerida por nuestras
células humanas es un alimento rico que
propicia el crecimiento del microbioma
de células buenas más aún nosotros
podemos y esto va dirigido más hacia las
futuras mamás antes de que ellas si
tienen la decisión entre una cesárea y
un parto natural es preferible un parto
natural ya que este es el momento cuando
el microbioma del bebé se forma y como
ustedes saben sería lo mejor que puede
suceder es que éstos adquieran las
bacterias benéficas de la madre
a que a pesar de que falta mucho por
descubrir
creo que nos estamos dando cuenta que
estamos el comienzo de una revolución
una revolución que está revalorizando el
rol del microbioma en nuestra salud y
que en los próximos años nos va a
permitir exterior terapias que pueden
ser usados para tratar muchas
enfermedades gracias
[Aplausos]